chat bot virtual agent chatterbot and ai
bot
what do these phrases even mean are they
the same thing can i use them
interchangeably
let's find out hi i'm morgan with ibm so
to figure this out we've got to talk
about the progression of chat bots over
time
so the very first chat bot to be
invented was actually in 1966
and her name was eliza
so eliza's sole purpose was to provide
responses to users based on different
keywords so since she was the first chat
bot they were like hey let's see if we
can make something
automated that's going to respond to
what users say
so think of it as like a bunch of if
then statements
if we say to eliza
for instance i like apples she's going
to take the keyword apples and then give
us some sort of response based on that
she's literally just looking for a
keyword and giving us a canned response
if i say something about
you know i have two dogs and their names
are apollo and mr hubble she's going to
take the keyword dogs and then give me
some response based on that so it's not
super customizable you know she's not
going to have like a human conversation
with me but she's going to be able to do
some relatively basic things
so this is called a rule-based chatbot
next we're going to fast forward to the
2000s
now this chat bot was named alice
alice stands for
artificial language internet computer
entity
which is a lot of words to say
that alice's sole purpose was to use
pattern recognition to have
conversations with people that was
literally it she was just there to act
as a human just in order to communicate
she actually serves as the foundation
the technology that she's based on is
the foundation for most chatbots these
days
there is a concept of something called
the turing test
and what that means is if a chat bot can
be tested by humans and the human can't
determine whether it's a human on the
other side or a chat bot
then they fail the turing test but
if i'm performing this test on a chat
bot and i can't tell if it's a human or
a chat bot then they pass
unfortunately alice did not pass but she
did win a lot of awards for her work
now i'm sure everyone is familiar with
apple's siri
so this was kind of the first
entry into using a chat bot as a
personal assistant you know you take out
your phone you say
hey siri i'd like to place an order or
what is the weather or can you send a
text message and stuff like that
so
she was kind of the first in this sense
to
give us a sort of concierge experience
and that kind of led into
also in the 2010s home assistance
so when i say home assistant
think about
mostly a smart speaker
most of us have either an alexa or
google home or something like that in
our home
so if i tell my alexa hey alexa start my
day she's going to be able to do a ton
of different things
she can you know turn my thermostat to a
different temperature she can turn on
all the lights she can tell me what the
news is
and the weather and all that kind of
stuff so this is when we start getting
into
more intelligent chat bots
which leads us to 2016.
now in 2016
we had what is called the ai
boom
ai artificial intelligence what this
means is that we are essentially
integrating ai into
everything in our daily life so whether
it's a
smart device or a chat bot ai is there
so
when we think about
what is a virtual agent
let's say we have our chat bot
and her name is going to be sally
i can tell sally a number of different
things and she's going to be able to
understand
what i mean no matter how i say it
so over here you know rule base we would
have to look for a specific keyword like
apple or something like that but like
what do you do with the apple or what do
i want the apple to be you know a
specific type well sally is really smart
she's using natural language processing
to figure out exactly what it is that i
want she can connect to a bunch of
different services so think um
if you want to make a
check and order status for instance i
ordered some shoes and i'm wondering
where are they they haven't gotten here
i can ask sally hey sally where are my
shoes she can connect to the specific
shops database and check the status of
where my shoes are
and then say
oh your shoes were delivered you have to
check your front porch something like
that
like i said before she can also
control different smart devices so if i
am hungry i say sally
start the oven you know preheat the oven
to 350. she's able to go
into this specific integration and
communicate with the oven
that leads us to
what about what's going to happen in the
future
so
we could
have potentially chips embedded into our
brains so that we don't have to
communicate with a chat bot via
voice or text or anything it can just
read our minds so i can subscribe
and know exactly what we want without us
having to say anything at all
possibility
so back to the original question we've
got chat bots virtual agents chatterbots
and ai bots
what's the difference we started with a
rule based chat bot over here which is
very simple looking for specific
keywords or specific patterns but it's
not really doing very much it's just
taking some input and giving us
something out and this is what eliza and
alice are doing
over here we've got our virtual agents
or our ai bots now they're intelligent
they use natural language processing
they can connect to
a ton of different services and do many
many things so that's what siri and our
home assistants are doing and we're
currently in the ai boom
and that's the difference between all of
these terms
thank you if you have questions please
drop us a line below if you want to see
more videos like this in the future
please like and subscribe